Let's go next to Sara from one of
my favorite cities in the world,
Montreal, Quebec, Canada. Sara, you're on the air.
Hello. Can you hear me? Yes, I can.
OK, so I guess I just wanted to know,
what do you think about Canada designing
the proud boys as a terrorist group?
I think because I think yeah, when I
when I was asked about it last week,
I obviously agreed colloquially, but
I didn't understand what it meant,
legally speaking, in Canada. And people
have emailed me since and explained that
by designating it a terrorist group, it actually
allows law enforcement more mechanisms and leeway
for pursuing and prosecuting the group and that
it has legal significance in Canada. So I agree
with it in the general sense, and it sounds
like it will be useful to Canada as well.
Yeah. Do you think there's going to be any
similar things done like that in the States or
you don't really think anything's
going to happen about that?
I don't know. I don't know. I mean,
obviously, it's more likely that
a Biden White House would push for designating
the proud boys as a terrorist group than in
a Trump White House. I don't know that it's a
priority for the Biden White House to do that.
OK, other follow up question is, did we talk about
martial law in the U.S. when the capital thing
happened? Right. And if you knew about the law of
war, that the guys. So it's like the war measures
were enacted in Quebec in the 70s and the army
took control of the country, the province, because
of like terrorist group, the Flik.
You know, if you heard anything about that,
I'm not familiar with that particular
incident, but I've done some reading
about instances, short term instances in many
countries over the last 40, 50 years where
there have been declarations where the military
does take over and and see that. You know,
one of the problems, Sara, is that
when we look at historical examples,
there are many of historical examples of martial
law being declared by authoritarian dictators who
want to remain in power. And then you also have
examples where there was a legitimate use and
reason for that declaration. And so you really
have to look at the details of every situation.
Yeah, not for sure. But anyways, I suggest you
look into it and all the information is mostly
in French. Yeah. It's like a bias between the two
languages of how they interpret the events. But
if you have time, my French reading isn't bad.
You know, sometimes when I watch a French show,
I will watch it with the French subtitles and
that's actually enough for me to understand it.
OK, that's cool. But if ever Kennebec is kind
of the communist health care the U.S. fears.
So I love Quebec. I have to tell you, it's
so great there. It's such a you're it's the
it's such a European experience, you know?
Yeah. Well, one day the borders will open
again and you could come over.
I would love to go. And so are
you. What general area in Montreal are you in?
I'm in like the Southwest, so it's like Vietnam.
So it's like very working class kind of
thing. But I'm kind of like the I guess,
yuppie, which is like I work in video games.
So I have a little bit of money, but I'm still
for student debt, so I live in a kind of working
class neighborhood now Southwest, that's not like
the Attwater market, right? Attwater market is
more like say yes. Yeah. It's like close to that
as course materials. Erections are weird because
the north is the north of the river, the north.
So everything is really confusing for that.
There's a similar thing in societies where
what seem oftentimes what is north on the
map, the city is kind of rotated relative
to the river. And so. And in fact, Manhattan
is the same thing. Oftentimes Manhattan is
portrayed as the avenues running perfectly
north south. But that's just for visual aids.
It's it's actually at an angle that's interesting.
Yeah, it's it's yeah. It's so weird things. And
people get confused when they first come in.
But, Sarah, one more question for you. Have
you ever been to the Vietnamese
food stall at the Attwater market?
I have not. I highly recommend
it. I highly recommend it.
OK. There's a lot of great food in Montreal,
so there is just like a lot of food to eat.
But yeah. Thank you for taking my call. All right.
My pleasure. Sarah from Montreal, great to hear
from you. We're going to take a very quick
break, but if you're holding on to talk to me,
don't hang up unless you're furious that
I've not picked up your call already. But
hang on, because we're going to take a
few more calls right after the break.